tania escalaba una montaña comenzó su
caminata a una altura de 1200 metros y
ascendió a una velocidad constante
después de 4 horas alcanzó una elevación
de 1700 metros se halla la
representación de la elevación de tania
en metros después de equis horas y nos
preguntan esto es de un ejercicio de
khan academy completa la ecuación que
describe la relación entre la elevación
y el número de horas si estuvieras en
khan academy lo escribiría aquí pero
podemos hacerlo a mano así que pausa el
vídeo y resuelve lo en un papel y veamos
si llegamos al mismo resultado muy bien
hagamos esto juntos en primer lugar nos
dicen que está ascendiendo a una
velocidad constante de modo que eso es
una buena indicación de que podríamos
describir su elevación en función del
número de horas que viaja con una
ecuación lineal podríamos incluso
averiguar esa velocidad constante dice
que va de 1200 metros a 1700 metros en
cuatro horas
entonces podríamos decir que su tasa de
cambio será su cambio en la elevación
sobre su cambio en el tiempo de modo que
su tasa de cambio en elevación es de
1700 metros menos 1200 metros y lo hace
durante cuatro horas sobre cuatro horas
el cambio en el tiempo es de cuatro
horas así que su tasa de cambio es
constante aquí en el numerador 1700
menos 1200 es igual a 500 metros ella es
capaz de subir 500 metros en cuatro
horas si dividimos 500 entre 4 es igual
a 125 metros por hora y podríamos usar
esto ahora para pensar cuál sería
nuestra ecuación nuestra elevación que
será igual a bueno en donde empieza está
empezando en 1200 metros entonces ella
está empezando a 1200 metros y a esto le
vamos a sumar cuánto sube según la
cantidad de horas que ha viajado de modo
que va a ser esta tasa de cambio 125
metros por hora multa
por el número de horas que ha estado
caminando entonces el número de horas es
x por equis esto que tenemos aquí es una
ecuación para la relación entre la
elevación y el número de horas otra
forma en la que podríamos pensar en esto
es bueno esta va a ser una ecuación
lineal porque está ascendiendo a una
velocidad constante podríamos decir que
la forma intersección pendiente para una
ecuación lineal que es igual a mx + b
donde b es su intersección en y cuál es
el valor de ye cuando x es igual a 0 y
diremos de acuerdo cuando x es igual a 0
ella está en una elevación de 1200 de
modo que m es nuestra pendiente así que
esa es la velocidad a la que nuestra
elevación está aumentando y eso es lo
que calculamos aquí nuestra pendiente es
de 125 metros por hora así que fíjense
estos son equivalentes tengo estos dos
términos intercambiados por lo tanto
podríamos escribir
es igual a 1200 125 x o podríamos
escribirlo al revés 125 x más 1.200 son
equivalentes